how many alien races are there anyway
welcome to the science asylum I am Nick
lucid we noticed something weird
happening around kic 8 4 6 - 8 5 -
that's a star in case you're wondering
there's a massive structure of small
irregularly sized objects aliens
probably not aliens it could be a whole
bunch of comments but they're not moving
like comments usually do definitely
aliens alright alright we'll consider
aliens for a few minutes it would help
if we knew how many aliens there might
be and it shouldn't be surprising that
people have had this discussion before
arguably the most famous estimates come
from the Drake Equation it considers a
bunch of factors we care about the rate
at which stars are born in our galaxy
the fraction of stars that have planets
the average number of planets per star
that could support life the fraction of
those planets that actually develop life
and the fraction of those planets that
develop intelligent life it also
considers some factors we don't care
about like the fraction of intelligent
races that learn to communicate by radio
waves and the length of time those races
use those radio waves this equation is a
great place to start because it's just a
bunch of multiplying unfortunately we
don't care if we can communicate with
them just if they exist I mean they're
probably not screaming in all directions
via radio wave anyway so let's tweak
this a little first we can get rid of
all that radio stuff but now the units
are in civilizations per year which
isn't very helpful we could include how
long the civilizations last before going
extinct but that's kind of depressing so
let's just imagine they evolved beyond
the universe or something multiplying by
time gives us units of civilizations
solving our problem it still doesn't
consider space travel or colonization of
other planets but that calculation is
way more complicated we've got pretty
good estimates for the first few numbers
both NASA and the European Space Agency
say the rate of star formation is seven
stars per year thanks mostly to the
Kepler telescope we know what fraction
of stars have planets pretty much all of
them so the fraction is about one or 100
percent the average number of planets
that could support life is a bit smaller
for a planet or a large moon to be
habitable it has to be a certain
distance from its star not too hot not
too cold but just right which is why we
call it the Goldilocks zone also thanks
to Kepler this turns out to be about
point four planets per star in other
words of
40% of stars have planets in their
Goldilocks zone the rest of the numbers
we know almost nothing about which means
we get to talk out of our butts oh oh
can I start sure yeah if life can
develop it will develop life is awesome
like that intelligent life is the
ultimate goal of life because duh and
civilizations they last forever you
can't use infinity oh man okay let's go
with a billion years okay so if we take
that really optimistic viewpoint
seriously when we multiply all that out
we get about 2.8 billion civilizations
in our galaxy since there are about 100
billion stars in the galaxy that's one
civilization for every 35 stars which is
pretty impressive yeah it is
don't be ridiculous bad clones bad sorry
well you're not like would develop
depends on so many factors so many the
ultimate goal of life is just to survive
and reproduce there's no reason to think
that intelligent life is anything
special also one the birds are strong
ourselves so I'm surprised me that's
additional that's awfully pessimistic
but let's take a look anyway multiplying
that out we get about 1 times 10 to the
negative 11 civilizations or one
civilization for every 100 billion
galaxies since there are only about 100
billion galaxies in the universe
that's one intelligent civilization for
the whole universe us that's way too
pessimistic and we already know there's
at least two I'm personally a bit more
moderate in my estimates I get a little
over 400 civilizations in our galaxy
which means the civilizations are an
average of about 5,000 light years apart
considering kic 8 4 6 - 8 5 - is about
1,500 light years away and that
civilizations probably won't be evenly
distributed it's not another question -
think there could be an alien structure
around that star so are you an optimist
a pessimist or moderate let us know in
the comments thanks for liking sharing
and subscribing and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy